- À moins de trois semaines
des élections, les partisans
du premier ministre Viktor Orban
ont répondu en grand nombre
à son appel à la mobilisation.
En ce jour de fête nationale,
ils sont venus d'un peu
partout en Hongrie
lui réitérer leur appui.
Ces jeunes espèrent
une victoire de la formation
de Viktor Orban.
Malgré l'inflation,
papapartisans vantent
notamment sa gestion de
l'économie hongroise au cours
des 12 dernières années.
- The country is in a better
e e e than ever.
- "Le pays n'a jamais été
en aussi bonne santé",
ajoute cet homme.
Mais pour ses adversaires,
après trois mandats consécutifst
en pleine dérive autoritaire.
L'opposition tente le tout
pour le tout pour le défaire.
Cette année, six partis se sont
unis derrière Peter Marki-Zay,
le maire conservateur
d'une petite ville du pays.
Une alliance aussi
inusitée qu'incontournable,
selon cet élu écol
de Budapest, qui déplore
les impacts de la transformation
de la Hongrie depuis
plus d'une décennie.
GABOR EROSS, élu du 8e
arrondissement de Budapest
- Les jeunes s'en vont,
les forces vives, comme on dit,
de la nation sont sur le départ,
donc si on la remporte pas
cette fois-ci, je ne sais pas
ce qui va rester de ce pays.
- Depuis des années,
les adversaires de Viktor Orban
lui reprochent de s'attaquer à
l'indépendance de la justice et
des médias et de porter atteint.
Au cours des dernières semaines,
c'est surtout sa relation avec
Vladimir Poutine qui a alimenté
les attaques de l'opposition.
"Nous devons choisir l'Europe
plutôt que l'Est", a lancé
le candidat de l'opposition.
Une atta p p p p peine voilée
à l'endroit de Viktor Orban,
qui a fait de Moscou un allié
central de la politique
étrangère hongroise,
tant sur le plan
quququququque que stratégique.
PETER BALAZS, prof. émérite,
Université d'Europe centrale
- On peut dire que son meilleur
ami, c'est Vladimir Poutine
parce qu'ils ont eus s s s s s .
Chaque année, ils se sont
rencontrés, jusqu'à la pandémie.
- Depuis le début de la guerre
dans l'Ukraine voisine,
le premier ministre hongrois
a ajusté ceeeeee
ses positions. Généralement
hostile à l'immigration,
Viktor Orban a permis l'accueil
de centaines de milliers de
réfugiés sur son territoire.
rement en conflit avec
Bruxelles, il a même approuvé
les sanctions de l'Union
européenne contre la Russie.
enenenenenenent somme toute
limité, constate cet ancien
ministre des Affaires
étrangères.- Il a soutenu les ds
de l'Union européenne,
les sanctions contre la russie.
Mais en même temps, il a fait
des déclarations en faveur
de la Russie, où il a montré
une certaine compréhension
pour les revendications
du gouvernement russe
de M. Poutine.
- Devant ses partisans,
Viktor Orban répète qu'il refuse
toute implication militaire dans
le conflit. Il s'est aussi
opposé à ce que des armes
transitent par la Hongrie.
Sa stratégie : se présenter
en défenseur de la paix
dans un pays qui a lui-même
une histoire t
avec Moscou. Rien d'étonnant,
pour ces électeurs indépendants.
Selon lui,
est prêt à tout pour gagner
cette élection, dans ce pays
marqué, plus que jamais,
par d'importantes divisions.
Ici Raphaël Bouvier-Auclai
Radio-Canada, à Budapes